hey guys so a few weeks ago I went to
CES and a lot of you guys are still
confused as to what CES actually stands
for well let me resolve that issue it
stands for the Consumer Electronics Show
now not only was I at CES for my own
personal love and obsession of
technology but I was there with Spike TV
shooting a new segment called G Tech for
the GT TV show hey GP TV I'm just seeing
farik here to discuss the future of 3d
and all of your favorite consumer
technology this first episode is airing
this Saturday at 10:30 a.m. on Spike TV
now if you guys happen to watch the show
be sure to tweet to me or come back here
and leave a comment and let me know what
you thought about it so making this
video for two reasons number one to let
you guys know about the show what I hope
that you will check it out this Saturday
and number two to link you to all the
videos that I shot while I was at CES
now I know a lot of you guys have
probably seen all of these since it was
a few weeks ago but if you didn't I have
them posted on a couple of my youtube
channels here so I'm gonna link them all
below so while you're trying to decide
which video you're gonna choose I
thought I'd show you some outtakes pull
the magic of editing and I am so excited
I'm just seeing with GTECH and I felt
like I should see something else but
there's nothing else to say i'm justine
and this is GTECH this is yours
[Music]
what's up GT TV ok what's up GT TV I'm
here are you kidding me
I love reading quarters seriously ready
all right guys thanks so much for
watching hopefully by now you've already
watched all of these videos and you've
set your DVRs for the Saturday okay all
right thank you for watching and I will
see you guys in my next video which will
be very very soon it's probably gonna be
a vlog University or it could be a music
video or could even be an ascot Jake I
just don't know why my voice is going up
the side so I'm gonna stop talking
holiday right phasing technology from 3d
TVs to tablets to robots and from ever